you created the oscar-winning grandma
what was the biggest challenge you faced
in your acting career and what did you
get
from minari's grandma sunja
well it's not happened right
at the moment because i i had a long
career
i'm trying to build up my career you
know step by step
there's nothing just happen bang like
this
i don't believe that kind of thing and
this award means well sometimes it's
well it's happy very happy when you get
it
but me myself i don't believe in
in competition especially in our field
because we are comparing different
movies
different world so it wasn't
i'm just lucky tonight just luckier than
the other nominees luckier than them and
maybe
the who knows it's american hospitality
for the korean actor i
thank you our next question is from
variety jazz
variety jazz next question
congratulations on your win tonight brad
pitt was a producer on menari and you
just met him
for the first time what was that like
and if you could do a movie with him
what genre would you choose no
they would never happen with my english
and
the age you know i don't think so so i
don't dream
impossible dream so no
[Laughter]
no answer blacktreetv you're on
blacktruetv what do you think about the
new films that's telling a different
story about what the diversity of
asian uh the asian world uh
uh offers as far as real stories and not
just
kung fu flicks and this and that like
how do you feel about like real stories
coming
telling about different uh variety of
asian cultures
that's been coming out lately am i
gathering right
because i think you talking about
how i feel about if the diversity of
between asian and all different cultures
how do i feel about that
yes oh yes different type of story yeah
yes
i'm sure it's about time the sharing
different story is
uh i think it's very nice to understand
each other
and we should embarrass each embrace
each other
embrace each other because
without knowing or categorize them we
people are categorized like a black
white
yellow brown something like that that's
not nice way to just
divide like that you know i think
if we put all color together make it
more prettier even rainbow has seven
colors
so color doesn't matter gender doesn't
matter all them what
what else men and women or i don't like
to
divide divide like you know like this
men
woman or black and white yellow brown
or some other word the gender you know
gay or straight or something like that i
don't want that kind of things
just we we are equal human beings we
have have the same warm heart
so did i answer right or i'm not sure
that's so it's it's the opportunity for
us to sharing the story together
thank you our next question is access
scott
all right congratulations uh this is
i mean you got two really two big honors
tonight not
only the the academy award the only the
second
uh uh asian woman to walk away with this
award
but also brad pitt
yes i know you are willing to say it
you win double times tonight talk to me
about what it feels to be able to
represent
um and the pride you must be feeling but
to also
then have a moment with brad pitt like
didn't know you were gonna you were
gonna be here tonight
no i wasn't i saw him on the stage and
then
oh he called my name i can tell
he practiced a lot he didn't
mispronounce my name
then at that moment then when i got
there
i just lost was
what i supposed to say
should i begin or something so
thank you our next question is from
extra
this question from extra
oh first off congratulations this
is your first american film and you win
an oscar
and then as you just talked about it was
given to you from brad pitt
i mean my goodness and then we saw you
guys have a conversation as you walked
off stage
so i have to ask you what did you guys
talk about and what did he smell like
i didn't smell him i'm not dog
i didn't smell him no
well i've been watching him when when
when was his first
movie with that
he was young and with that oh i forgot
so i've been watching him he was a movie
star for me
so i couldn't believe
he was leading to me or he announced my
name
then so then i
maybe i just blacked out compliment a
couple seconds or so
what should i say where am i or
something like that
but um so i kept asking my friends am i
saying right
do they understand what i'm trying to
say something like this i'm still my not
myself
don't ask me too many questions please
and congratulations that was our last
question congratulations to our winners
thank you